i'm gonna be talking about every single  new mac that we should be expecting from  apple in 2022 so without further ado  let's get right into it the next new mac  that we should expect to see is the new  redesigned mac mini a reveal at their  march event would be perfect we have the  new 27-inch apple silicon imac base  model ships with a regular 5k lcd  display and then you'll have the option  of upgrading to the 120hz promotion mini  led version for a couple of hundred  dollars extra the new completely  redesigned m2 macbook air will have to  wait until at least october or november  to see the new design we'll be getting  an m2 entry-level macbook pro it's gonna  be revealed alongside the air there are  rumors from multiple sources pointing to  apple working on new external displays i  wouldn't expect any of these until at  least december of 2022 and then finally  we have the new apple silicon mac pro i  fully expect it to start shipping in  december